hi i'm danielle kane and today i'm
becoming elena
[Music]
i think what draws me to cosplay in
general is the transformation of
stepping out of your own shoes into
someone else's most of the characters i
cosplay they're usually strong women
we all wish to be a stronger person that
we were capable of doing way more than
we actually are can't think of anyone
who doesn't want to be a badass
i can't remember what sparked me to do
black widow but she was my first you
know superhero costume
i just find it so fascinating how elena
so jaded from her past
and with someone like natasha to
influence her
that she could be more than she thinks
she's capable of
i really do love the way she kind of
lives in the gray i don't like
characters that are
all good or all bad they're human like
us they make mistakes and they don't
always do the right thing but they have
a good heart
when i got the call about
cosplaying elena for marvel's becoming i
was naturally extremely nervous what i
really love about the black widow
community is that we're all cosplaying
essentially the same character now
there's elena too everyone's helping
each other to be the best black widow
they can be
having lauren as my black widow for this
has been really helpful because she's
made the vest before i actually spoke to
lauren and she
really convinced me to get on board then
i went full force into making this
costume i had been with the project for
a little bit longer so
you know being able to pass on any
resources that i had about sourcing
materials and what kind of fabrics
things
seem to be
it's really exciting getting to kind of
delve into a new character it's gonna be
like an a different journey and she's
not gonna
have the same path that natasha had
i've had a lot of people in the past ask
me how i make
a costume and it's so hard to explain
because it's not just one answer with
everything that i've done for elena i've
got a handful of new skills so i
definitely feel like i've evolved even
just this one costume since the one
prior so it's kind of exciting that if
someone's looking for help making their
elena i can actually be like i know i
can help i mean i would love to give
someone hope for something as big as
like a marvel character
black widow but he's pg-13 experience it
now